speaking of immaturity juju smith
schuster continuing to insist on dancing
on logos for road games it's one thing
when you do it at home on your own logo
when you do it on the road that becomes
a potential problem even though it's
juju just being juju and it's part of
his brand it's social media
once it starts riling opponents up then
it becomes something that the team needs
to
pay attention to here is coach mike
tomlin from earlier today on the subject
of juju's tick tock videos
while he dances on opponent logos
i am aware of it and i do plan to talk
to juju
but we're professionals i doubt any of
those antics and things of that nature
are legitimate motivating factors
uh as you step into professional
stadiums um but it's about respect and
and so we'll have a conversation uh but
i understand it's about the quality of
play
inside the white lines and so i'm not
seeking comfort or looking for excuses
uh based on our recent performances on
things that occur in pregame
or things of that nature that are social
media related
two points in response to coach tomlin
all due respect
when the opponent tells you it was a
motivating factor
how in the world are you saying it's not
when you see the ferocity of the hit
that von bell the bengals safety applied
to juju's miss schuster
and von bell said before the game
that's how we're gonna deal with dancing
on our logo and he made it clear
after the game that's how they dealt
with dancing on the logo so
it does potentially motivate the
opponent it is a gratuitous act that has
no strategic benefit of any kind
to the steelers and it's potentially
hurting the steelers so that
expletive deleted must end right now if
you are mike tomlin
two for as great of a coach as mike
tomlin is and i've had other coaches
around the league
praise his ability to strike the right
chord with every player and get the most
out of every player
it could be that tomlin develops these
weird blind spots where he lets guys do
certain things
as part of the broader effort to have
the right relationship with them and get
the most out of them remember
the antonio brown facebook live video
from the locker room after the playoff
win over the chiefs
and how stupid that was and tomlin had
it happening right under his nose
we since realized tomlin had a very
unique relationship with antonio brown
where there was some give and take and
some push and pull and allowing him to
be himself
in order to get the most out of him on
the field i think with juju's miss
schuster it's a different story and i
think you can go to him and you can say
hey juju that's it it's done no more
and you have enough evidence to make the
argument to him i think
the problem is tom may have already
boxed himself into the corner here by
shrugging at it in the past
and trying to shrug at it now the bottom
line is if i'm a steelers fan
i'm livid about this it has to end it's
not helping us
there's no point shireen and when they
go to play cleveland week 17
all eyes are going to be on that logo at
midfield and the last person i want to
see on it if i'm a steelers fan is juju
smith schuster
yeah mike this didn't become an issue
until they started losing and now that
they're in this three-game losing streak
it's an issue and tomlin admits he
didn't know about it until the bills
game when the bill sort of
made it an issue and now it is an issue
when as you said
when players from other teams are saying
they're using it as motivation you need
to stop doing it you don't need to
provide teams with more motivation i
realize this is the nfl they use
whatever they use
for motivation we've seen everything
we've seen stupid stuff they use for
motivation but they want to find that
and they want to push themselves
and so that if this is motivating other
players and it's obvious it is
he just needs to stop doing it don't do
it maybe do it after the game go make
your video after the game after you've
won maybe that's when
you do it and then there is no push back
because you've won the game
but something needs to change uh within
this team
obviously this before the game and then
with whatever they're doing in the game
because they
do not look like a super bowl contender
right now mike
yeah they don't and it's amazing how
quickly it's turned around for them from
11-0 to 0-3
and they legitimately could lose the
next couple of games
lose the division title to the browns
the ravens actually rooting for the
steelers because if the steelers win one
of the next two and the ravens win their
last two the ravens get in
if i'm the steelers i don't know what i
want the ravens in but
what i do want if i'm the steelers is to
figure out over the course of the next
two weeks
how i'm gonna win in the postseason
these next two games are the pre-season
to the postseason as far as i'm
concerned because home field advantage
doesn't really matter winning the
division doesn't really matter
not this year especially yeah you want
to be able to say you won the division
and we've wanted x number of times and
that's great
but you're already in the playoffs the
goal now
is to do everything you can to be ready
to win the weekend of january nine
treat the next two weeks as your tune up
to get there and
and that's what the steelers need to do
and we'll see if they can do it
i i was surprised last night by mike
tomlin's demeanor
at his post game press conference he
seemed resigned to the fact that team's
not very good
he said there's no reason for the
players to be confident currently but at
the same time
he thinks they can fix it i'm not sure
they can and maybe they needed to bottom
out
before they'll get better shireen but
they've bottomed out
and we'll see if they now that they're
at rock bottom will
climb out of the hole or continue to try
to dig when the colts come to town this
weekend
yeah you know big ben has not played
very well mike and he's not played very
well since that dallas game and i know
they keep
pointing out that his knees fine and he
hasn't been on the injury report
but he took a couple of hard hits on
both of his knees in that game he missed
the the end of the first half he did
come back and play the second half and
was able to pull out that win
but i just see a different big ben since
then
and it's been a different defense that
hasn't been able to pull the steelers
out with all the losses they've had
injury-wise on that defense
that defense just hasn't been able to
pull them out of those holes and
they now rank second on defense which
you know we still think they're they're
one of the top defenses in the league
but they certainly haven't played
haven't played like it since they've
taken some
real big hits on that defense and they
really need the defense to find itself
again even with some backup players but
especially they need big ben to find
himself if they're going to have any
hope of even winning one playoff game
might much less getting
beyond that injury report says he's
healthy
mike tomlin says he's healthy
rothersburger says he's not 100
but no one is if you don't have injury
as an excuse then
bad news you're just not very good right
now and it could be as we suggested
earlier today on pft live that ben's
just old
he's 38 he'll be 39 in march he's taken
a lot of wear and tear
he's carrying around a big body on that
frame at some point that frame is going
to rebel
and say enough is enough
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest
news and highlights from nbc sports